okay here we go
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen welcome back to
your
absolutely favorite podcast
[Music]
wow
welcome back to riverwood griffin y'all
it's good to be here uh
thank you for watching listening
subscribing today i got a special
episode uh
i can't wait um this is a
very nerdy gaming
orientated episode but i have
the scat stat geek of all stat geeks on
the show today mr jay god
um you know if you watch me on eric
griffin gaming you know
you know about this but he's a very
fascinating guy that's interesting so
welcome to real films
okay anyways yeah man so thanks for
listening subscribing
sharing thanks for doing all that stuff
for people on youtube thank you
people that just listened to the audio
thank you guys too so yeah today's sp i
have a guest on today so this is just
the intro part
his name is jay god real name is james
but you know we all call him jay god
he's like a great stat geek
and we just have a very interesting
conversation so if you've never heard of
if you've never played call of duty or
you know or have you ever heard about
somebody that like
you know takes stats and and somebody
that's like really
uh meticulous about that that's this guy
he's a very interesting dude and we have
a fun conversation if you're not into
gaming and stuff like that you want to
pass on this one i totally understand
but for all you gaming geeks
this is a good one then especially the
people that know who jay god is uh
so yeah so that's what this one's about
now i just a little warning little
disclaimer for the people watching on
youtube
for the first seven minutes of the video
his
video is choppy because i um he wasn't
in here live
but then it cleans up and then so for
the rest of the hour and whatever mean
time everything is fine so
just bear with it for the first seven
minutes but you people that are just
listening you're fine so you don't even
have to worry about it so
but once again and also remember make
sure you make sure you check me out on
eric griffin gaming
on twitch so i'm always uh there
and uh you know share subscribe like and
i hope you enjoy
uh this episode so here he is mr jacob
uh ladies and gentlemen uh welcome back
to roofing with griffin special riffing
with griffin uh
crossing with eric griffin gaming and
riffing with griffin all together in one
world
welcome to the podcast the man the myth
the legend
uh mr jay god welcome to the podcast my
friend
how's it going it's going good man uh
you know let me just say
just just off the bat like you know
like i'm a huge fan you know and i just
want to get into really like
like you know like where are you from
and like you know like how did you how
did you get into let's just start like
where are you from like
because you're in california right yes
i'm in california i've been in
california pretty much my whole life
um i've gone to a couple other states
like was uh
right after i graduated high school i
was in the marine corps reserve
oh thank you having to go to boot camp
in san diego which wasn't too far
and then um the year later i ended up
going to my
mos school stuff which was over in north
carolina
um for like a basic electrician and then
i did that while i was going to school
working full time
i was with my uh girlfriend which ended
up being my wife
uh that i got together with when i was
in high school pretty much stayed in
california the whole time
moved from the l.a area more to the
riverside area
um and that's kind of a little bit my
origin as far as my start like wherever
i live and locally where i'm at
sweet sweet all right and so then so
then what got you into
what got you into like doing like the
stats the way you do it because like
i mean it's so intensive
what you do so like
what started that you know what i mean
like what got you into like being
so meticulous
with the the stat crunching and to the
point where it's like you were
you're like you're the go-to you know
that right you know you're the go-to
for guns yeah it just it's kind of weird
how that kind of evolved
um because when i first started my
channel um about
almost three and a half years ago about
three and a half years ago four years in
august
um i was like you know what i'm gonna
do some cod videos before that i was
like you know what let me try and get a
little bit better at cod i started
watching youtube for the first time in
2017
um so i hadn't even like actually known
anything about youtube
joining like when i'm like 29 years old
30 years old and barely getting into
youtube
right but at least i had some work
experience so a lot of times i think
these younger people on youtube
they don't have that so it's kind of
hard for them to transfer over
and understand the business side of
youtube yeah um
so initially when i started i found a
channel exclusive ace
which was kind of more of a numbers guy
um
very data driven stuff and i related
with that because even when i used to
work in sales i was still kind of like a
numbers guy
very analytics which sometimes to a
fault which is sometimes as bad
but it ends up working out you know that
it transferred over to this
um but i also found another youtuber by
the name
uh or he's a streamer mainly but his
name was team emery
absolute demon like a 6kd and
um when i started watching it was like
one of those things where before that
i would look at the leaderboards and go
there's no way anyone can have a 6kd
that's just not real
right no they got to be cheating
something right yeah like in that
mindset that like a lot of people are
going through now
now that you know they don't just don't
realize how good people could be
so i started watching that i got into it
and then i improved dramatically like
overnight just from like watching
and focusing on content um and then i
was like you know what maybe i could
give this youtube thing a try maybe i
could fulfill a niche
which is to help players improve i think
there's a lot of good content on there
of best class setups or
you know gameplay just for pure
entertainment just because somebody's so
talented
they show that off but there wasn't a
lot of improvement stuff and i saw
myself go from like a 1.7 kd up to
almost like a four
in like a matter of like two or three
weeks from my overall stats but my
weekly stats were like
dramatically improved just by knowing
hey you know what you gotta look at the
mini map you gotta have the right
loadouts so
i saw the before and after like in real
time
and i go you know what i'm gonna try and
do that same thing for other people
but maybe focus my content around that
so when i first started my channel
it was all like tip based so i would
just play a match
and then i would do li li uh essentially
live commentary
or com commentary over the entire game
play
with an emphasis on giving tips around
my thought process
as i was playing because i think all
these good players are very talented
but they don't usually find a way to
articulate what they're thinking
because it requires a little bit more
effort because it's very easy to go on
there when you're super
talented drop a nuke and go hey you know
here's my nuke enjoy it
they have like three minute segments
where they're focused up and they don't
even talk
um their audience really doesn't
understand what is going on like
that they're looking at the map 47 times
per minute or something crazy
and it's like really that much like yeah
that much
so there's these little things that
nuance so i evolved from that
but i always wanted to do like a little
bit more stat based stuff and i always
saw like exclusive
ace is kind of untouchable in that sense
uh because
his content was so like evolved already
like he'd already been doing youtube for
five years
or something at that point so his stats
and all that stuff were good
and i spent one day when a new weapon
came out i was like you know i'm gonna
test everything i'm gonna focus on my
energy
took me like nine hours to test the one
weapon like
whereas now it would take probably like
two hours the same testing on that
weapon
right and um i uploaded and did terrible
on the channel it did horrible views and
i was like yep i'm not doing that again
and i was like that was a waste of my
time all that effort
like i was stressing out because you
know and then you're comparing yourself
oh you're just copying exclusive ace
type thing
and you hear a lot of that so i
eventually kept doing these uh
class setup videos but i always like was
debating people
it would be like the best ppsh class
setup
and then in the video i'd go hey best
piece i would open i wouldn't say hello
i'll just say the best ppsh class set up
is this this and this
and then i go well now that you have the
loadout if you want to like and
subscribe
go for it but the rest of the gameplay
i'm gonna talk about why i'm using this
weapon
and like how i'm playing the the map and
it kind of evolved from that
where i was debating people into tip
videos because most people don't think
they need the tip videos
right so i was debating them with class
setup videos to get them to my content
um and then i would just provide quality
content um so i did that for like two
and a half years three years
and then um during the process of war
zone or modern warfare when it first
dropped
there was a lot of attachments so it was
very
easy to kind of get thrown into hey you
know what let me test 47 things on one
weapon
and there was a lot of there was a lot
there was a lot of attachment that meant
there was gonna be a lot of content
there was a lot of
oh yeah yeah yeah so i went that route
and i started getting more involved in
that i was still doing
the things i was doing before but i
slowly was getting more efficient and
just better and more comfortable
in myself as a content creator and i did
more of the stat based stuff
and then um none of that was like going
crazy outrageous
um but then at a certain point i i
started doing content where i was the
only
xm4 class setup you need type thing and
then what i would do
is i would spend like a 12 15 minute
video there'd be zero gameplay
literally zero would just be my face
spreadsheets attachments
and i would just talk about here's these
and why this over this over this over
this
and the videos did stupid well i did one
for the growl it has like 900 000 views
which like for a class setup video
that's absurd like my class set of
videos would get like
30k 40k right that's still great like
almost a million you know
so it's kind of one of those things it's
like oh damn then i did the next one and
then the next one
and then you notice oh you know what
that content's doing better than my
game play where i have to sweat out and
skill-based matchmaking
and then talk about my thought process
it's like
i i'm going to dedicate more time to
that well well let me just let me just
tell you like
i appreciate even even how you talking
about this you're very meticulous and i
love that about you
and i think that that's what it is i
think people just
really ultimately appreciate um
they they appreciate like what the
effort that you put
into it and like just speaking for me
like you know a new season comes out
or a new gun comes out the first thing i
do
is go to your channel the first thing i
do is go where the hell is that
spreadsheet and when you don't update
the spreadsheet i'm furious with you
yeah yeah yeah i get comments of that
like hey you need to update this this
one's off by a number i'm like all right
cool let me go double check that
yeah do you find it but do you enjoy it
it's like you're so like you know it's
like
the fans are clamoring for it and you're
like does it become like a job or you're
like oh i got to go test this gun
and and do the recoil patterns and make
sure it could be tedious
when it's something that is like super
repetitive like
when a new weapon comes out it's usually
all right cool let me test this this
this and this like these five things
that are important
then maybe we'll focus on the finer
details um
but i think now that we're at a point
where
like the game is kind of stabilized on
attachments hopefully
it's not like i was going and testing
bullet velocities for like 17 weapons
where i have to load into plunder since
they don't have private matches that
work consistently
and then it becomes more of a chore but
i i need that to get to the end result
of what i really enjoy which is making
the content
you know what i mean i need that the
groundwork or else i can't make
the thing i want to make so it's kind of
like you have to do one
for the other and it's just kind of one
of those things that well i want to do
what i want to do but i can't do that
without doing the other thing
and then they went and changed all the
bullet velocities on everything it was
like
all right i just spent nine like nine
hours straight just
tediously landing in blunder some people
being annoying and shooting okay i gotta
back out and re-cue
wasted 15 minutes there oh you know what
now i can't find the time stamp on my
my video because i ended up getting a
gunfight and spent five minutes dealing
with these weirdos
you know so it's sometimes that tedious
part can be annoying when it's back to
back to back to back to back
um of testing but luckily they haven't
really done a huge overhaul
where they've made it so that has been a
thing where it feels more like a chore
because it's like
all right cool i spent two hours testing
something and then i prep
the things for a video and then i do the
video i edit the video upload the video
make the thumbnail you know
you know the whole process yeah um
whereas two hours three hours testing
not bad nine to ten hours a day like
that gets more like
grindy and it doesn't feel as like all
right cool now let me make a video type
thing
um but i'm glad the game's kind of at a
point where they did change all these
things they gave us pretty specific
numbers
we'll start to kind of go ahead and
manually test things but it's not like
so urgent that i have to do it today the
the the numbers that they give us is
enough to make a video off of so i can
at least get that content out
there's probably a couple outliers where
it's like all right cool i'll make a
video on that one that one and that one
and that gives me another three videos
and then like that's where i can drive
my content
and then at some point there might be an
outlier where maybe they messed up
what they said and it ended up being
better than it was so then that could be
a surprise
and that's great for small content
creators because if they put that
content out
then it's like all right j god did you
see this yes
all right cool so now that guy got a
bunch of views on it then i'm gonna say
hey
by the way so and so found out this and
they kind of get a shout out so it's
kind of one of those things
yeah that works but let me ask you um
why warzone why call of duty um what is
what is it because like for me i'll just
tell you for me i think it's like
i love the it's such a challenging game
that gets me
at so many emotional levels i have the
highest highs and the lowest lows
but that adrenaline rush and and um i
think it's a perfect amount of like
the time to kill i think the time to
kill and i want to ask you about this
too but
first let me ask you about why war zone
why call of duty why
modern warfare so way back when i i've
always played call of duty i remember
getting the first original cod for
uh modern warfare like on my xbox 360 i
think it was or whatever
i played that i didn't even have online
at that time because online was kind of
weird
where the the internet providers weren't
good or whoever i was living with at the
time didn't have the right internet
so where you could play you had to have
like a the little wi-fi
adapter for your xbox that you weren't
even hardwired i mean it was a terrible
gaming experience
but i played that loved the campaign and
then i played a little bit of
multiplayer when i go over to like my
cousin's house or whatever
and then over time i got kind of hooked
on multiplayer and it was kind of one of
those things i was part of that cod hype
where they were breaking shattering like
expectations and just sales and
and just destroying games like
battlefield and halo kind of dipped off
and it wasn't even competition
and they were like the game during black
ops 2
modern warfare 2 modern warfare 3 around
that bubble i played cod
every single year like every single year
and i invested more time into that game
every year
than i would other games because you buy
a campaign it's like 6 to 10 hours
yeah you knock it out and that's it you
never touch it again versus cod
it's like oh yeah i got 10 days played
that's 240 hours you know it's kind of
crazy to think about and there's people
who have like 40 days played or
something
so that was the logical transition when
i started my channel i was like you know
what i enjoy cod i play cod every year
they come out the new one so that's
great for content um
and then there's like easy transition
there
then when war zone dropped i initially
didn't think i was gonna like it
most battle royales i give them about a
month i play them
and then i get bored and i move on um
why do you get bored
i think it's just kind of like there's
nothing
to like improve on
you know what i mean like for me it
feels weird like because when fortnite
dropped
that was the first real br that i gave a
chance as soon as i got a hundred wins
then i was like all right well what what
do
like they don't have camo grind in that
thing they don't have nothing
like it's just get wins get kills and
buy character skins that's like not
i'm not a i'm not a shop guy i don't buy
anything from the store
and uh then apex legends dropped and i
was like all right cool i gave this like
three weeks and i was like all right
cool we got some
wins and it's cool but like
it's like uh where the hell is the draw
and i think a lot of times for me
was the rng factor and the fact that you
once you're dead if you play with people
you're dead for the next 25 minutes like
that's not fun that's
disengaging real quick yeah blackout had
kind of like a respawn system once they
came out with those later modes but even
blackout i
really like enjoy unless i was playing
with people i knew that were playing and
jump in with them and it'd be cool but
besides that i was a multiplayer guy
and it was consistent with that but
because that buyback situation
then once warzone dropped they did
loadouts yeah and it was like
oh my god that's like if they didn't
have loadouts i don't know what people
would be posting on warzone
right because 99 of the content is
uh best mp5 best
yeah yeah yeah yeah you know meta yeah
he's like what would be hey i dropped 30
kills again
i dropped 40 kills again with whatever
gun it was i found on the floor
like that's what every other battle
royale does okay so like speaking of the
battle royales just to like uh cause
like
man you you your energy is like you i i
know that you could talk about this for
hours and i
i i i i can't tell you how much i
appreciate you i'm gonna keep saying
that it's just cause
it's like you know you know it's kind of
like somebody that's really into fantasy
football or fantasy sports
and then there's the people that are
outside are like it's not real and i
hate when people say that
because i'm like i enjoy this this is my
escape
and for someone like yourself to like be
you're
it's so meticulous you're so into it
it's so like a
serious and it's so well thought out so
i just want you to know from the cod
universe and the people everybody that
watches my channel you are 100
appreciated okay i just want you to know
that
but let's discuss this this now because
i love how you were comparing the
the different games and for me i
personally think that
what makes warzone the best one is
the time to kill let me just ask you
this
the to me the longer the time to kill
the more it benefits a more skilled
player
always yeah and so for me the um
the the um let me turn this down a
little bit for me the
the uh um so then like the higher time
to kill
it means that a common average player
or someone just coming in they actually
have a chance to win
a gun fight no matter what and i think
that's what makes the appeal
because apex legends you got to use like
two clips to kill somebody
oh you're gonna be 100 accurate even if
you're 100 accurate
and like a big nag it's 25 bullets
you know and i'm just like i don't have
that skill level to like you know
you know what i mean and then and then
pub g it looks like pac-man uh you know
you know what i mean like the graphics
are [ __ ] you know
yeah and so then you know what i mean
and then you know so like again and then
i thought blackout was actually
super challenging like you know what's
hilarious i've never won
a solo blackout all right i've to this
day i've tried
so many i've never won but i have over
200 victories in warzone
you know so it's like i think that it's
at the
sweet spot of pros
and average players can play together
and everyone can shine yeah
what do you think about that i
definitely think that's on point i think
the
the their overall goal is to raise the
ttk to
to increase the skill gap just a little
bit because there's too many instances
where the guns are
super easy to use especially the metal
weapons where
literally you can just aim pull down a
little bit and you're going to hit your
shots
and that's easy for most players so a
lot of times if the ttk is too low
then it feels like you get punished for
moving
versus somebody gets rewarded for
standing still
because if you happen to walk by someone
they shoot you in the back
the ttk is too fast then you don't have
a chance to react
and potentially at least have a chance
or feel like you had a chance in the
gunfight
to react and slide into a cover or
something
to reset that gun fight um so i think
that the balance is there
and i think it's getting to a sweet spot
because there's also the other aspect
where if the ttk is too high
well now you can't like your chances of
taking on a 1v2
drop considerably now you got to take on
one guy
and he's more likely to deal damage to
you because now the ttk is faster
he can react so it's a fine balance
that i think they're doing okay with and
they've gotten better with in the past
six months
especially once ravens started being
more proactive about patch notes and
and being very meticulous about what
their overall goal is in
expressing that goal versus hey you know
what it's been three months let's modify
one weapon by one stat and hopefully
that changes everything
no they're like yeah let's let's modify
38 weapons and and
we're going to make a big shake up to
things and probably they had to do
i think they've made this change too
also after
the dmr meta time that
that what i consider a debacle but at
the same time though
there's a part of me that feels they do
that on purpose
i feel like they go yeah we gotta have a
metagun that anybody can use to draw
people into playing
because like if you dropped into a game
for the first time and you're just
getting
wrecked by like everybody you're just
kind of like why would i want to play
this
the the the learning curve is too high
to get there but if i could drop in and
grab this gun that it's just like wow
this is
fun i mean do you think they do that on
purpose is that the reason for meta
because what do you think is the reason
for having a metagun in your opinion
well
i think no matter what there's going to
be a meta just because people inherently
want to min max stuff
uh but usually the the the meta and then
between the viable weapons usually the
if the gap is so large
then that's it has to be designed like
dmr
was completely broken in every regard
and
anyone just looking at the numbers could
have said yep that's stupid broken
and basically they went in and they
modified
all the stats but if the gap was this
big then it's very hard like to not use
this thing
right but when they've done it now where
obviously there is a clear meta but the
gap is much smaller
yeah you could use some other stuff and
you know that if you run into one of
these you're a little bit
at a disadvantage but it's not like
you're guaranteed you're gonna lose
regardless if you're not using that
okay but oh no okay i love this okay on
that line though
what i hate is they have a meta
everyone complains so now actually i
feel like we've learned our lesson
so like the gra metadays we were like
what is happening
and then they changed it and then we
were upset then it was the fal meta days
we were like this is outrageous
now we're kind of like oh they're doing
this on purpose so now we're just kind
of like all right we're just waiting for
them to nerf it
but yeah but my problem now is like they
nerf
the guns to the ground where they're
unusable
and i don't understand why they do that
like what do you think
like when the tactical og was a meta it
was like all right but they didn't have
to do it
take away from it where now no one uses
it why do they do that do you think they
do that on purpose or what's your
feeling no i don't think they do that on
purpose
i think there's some weapons
particularly with burst is that
they have this fine line where it goes
overpowered
and then trash there's no in between
because if it's slightly better in one
area
or the other it automatically becomes
broken i think
there's certain weapons that are like
that there are not that the rd90s like
that
yep are not because like the r90 the
problem with the r90 is
is that it's that two-shot hitch so it's
either gotta be a two-shot kill
or it's trash yep you know what i mean
yeah exactly
exactly because that third shot ends up
putting that big old
600 millisecond delay between burst
and now you have like a thousand ttk
instead of 600 which
right that's not competitive up close
yeah it's not it's just not like there
are 90s one of those guns where they go
well we either got to make it really
good but that
i get it with that one but a lot of the
other ones like you know
for a long time the milano was just like
an unusable gun
yeah and then they did a little change
to it now you know everyone's using it
but
i feel like i do agree with you with the
gun balancing
i feel like right now that the gun
balancing is at a really good place
because now you got your mp5 you got the
milano you got the
even that even that psh i always call it
the piece of [ __ ]
because it was like for a little while
yeah
just because but now i think they did
something to it where it's a little
better
but like you know so now you go you have
them you see you you're not running into
the same gun
every single time so but at the same
time though
is that good for the game or is it
better that like
when it's like we're all challenged
against that one gun
um i think it's better when there's
balance because there's a little bit
more variety in the game
um in terms of what you run up against
and i think there's certain pros and
cons to certain weapons
and it adds enough versatility because i
know one thing that like get keeps me
from playing the game sometimes is if
the
meta is too one-sided like at a certain
point i was like yeah i'm tired of using
the amax but i'm not going to use
anything else so i'm just not going to
play
you know it's kind of one of those
things where it just gets
too much of an issue where there's
nothing to use long range now
you can use the pharah of the c58 after
the buff the qbz i don't i thought i'd
never say that but i thought i'd never
say that about the milano
they figured that part out and then you
know you have the qbz
you still have the uh the stoner the rpd
the like you have a bunch of weapons
that you can literally use for long
range
and it's not like haha you're going to
be screwed or you would talk smack and
someone grab that loadout it's just not
going to happen yeah but what about like
oh man you know the gun that just drives
me bananas and they keep jamming it down
our throat
is that m sixty like get it
off the ground oh yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah i
think you're gonna be like around now i
think it's off the ground
i mean oh my i was like it's always it's
in the gulag it's in the pre-game
i'm like get it out of here or make it
better
yeah i keep telling my friends like
they're gonna make the m60 meta you
watch
next season they're gonna like you know
do something to it and everybody's gonna
be using it but it's like those kind of
guns
i wonder why have that gun in the game
if it's going to be they have to know
it's unusable what do you
like what is your answer to that well i
think one thing that's happened even in
previous call of duty's is uh you kind
of see these typical trends
where in like multiplayer there was
weapons that were clearly designed
for hardcore there would be trash in
multiplayer but they'd be good
in um hardcore because they would do
like 30 damage or something
so it was guaranteed a one shot kill at
range
um versus in multiplayer you needed like
six shots and it has slow fire rate
so really you would get dumpstered in
because of the health difference
but the fact that you know you can get
one shot
or vice versa there'd be a gun that does
28 damage so you need two shots in
hardcore
but because of the fire rate it would be
excel in multiplayer gotcha i think
it's one of those things that like maybe
the m60 just sucks because they need to
figure
some damage and values out because it's
slow firing but it hits the same as
most of the other lmgs in cold war um
so there's that aspect to it but then
there's also that
you know you're balancing against three
games so like right okay that makes
sense because i feel like every gun
is great in multiplayer like i mean you
know any gun you pick up in multiplayer
you have a chance to win so yeah so i so
i do understand that
but there are certain weapons man that i
really love
i try like on my channel they know i
retire
guns okay well here's another retirement
ceremony but i keep bringing it out of
retirement you know what gun is that
the scar why is that gun
why isn't it really like to me it's just
it's not you it's so damn jumpy now this
is what i don't understand
if you're going to make a gun shoot so
slow then it should hit hard
yeah you know you don't understand like
like for instance the odin
i think that odin's a great gun but
there's something funky about it that
you don't see a lot of people
slow fire rate the recoil and the small
mag instantly
make it hard to use okay so now you get
i have so many questions like here's
another thing
because now i'm asking like another
thing about that is
when it comes to like it seems to me
like
they should take the the modern warfare
guns and the cold war guns
they need to like somehow bring the best
of both worlds to the other
so for instance the sky if the scar had
a 40 clip
they don't need to change it at all it
would be fine yeah yeah 45 round mag is
what i what i did the numbers on where
it would make sense
if we had a 45-round mag it'd be dope
and then all but also on the other guns
i would like some of those perks from
the from the modern world oh yeah yeah
fully loaded
fully loaded yeah or whatever yeah yeah
like like you know so do you think
they're ever gonna do that or like
i don't think so i i think it's kind of
a annoying in some senses because
i do it uh the thing where i do top 10
loadouts and i always have two loadouts
that are like for your
your ghost and your you know restock
um i have those always set up and
they're always set up with uh
the scikov now and the growl and i
use the growl because it's one of the
best
non-optic long range yeah but also
modern warfare guns
like you know yeah and you don't need to
put and you don't need to put
five attachments the four attachments
are great and then you can get fully
loaded
yeah m4 is another example of that amex
is an okay example of that
but those are only like three guns but
the grouse still supreme has better ads
where you don't need that dac laser or
the rubberized grip or a 3x optic
you can get away with having fully
loaded when you drop back and fit zone
you're like i have to get a load out
boom you grab it you're fully loaded and
um
i i think that would be available to
maybe like two
maybe two or three other weapons would
be in the mix if they were cold war guns
um i'm not sure off the top of my head
but
i would imagine that would be like two
or three where you go oh yep i'm gonna
grab that i'm gonna get fully loaded
with this gun and then you're good to go
um let me get to my list of things now
because like you i could tell that you
and i could we could just
we'll have to do part two of this i mean
i mean i love this so much
um okay let me get to this now here's
one of my things
i love cross platform i think cross play
is great
but in this game i do feel
there is a clear advantage to mousing
keyboard players
and i really wish there was a way that
you could go
console only not just xbox with xbox ps
ps5 and ps5 but those people play and
then we get rid of these mouse and
keyboard people
what's your thoughts on that on the
different on those two because it's
a clear or maybe you don't think there
is but i feel like
i don't think there is a clear i think
the biggest advantage right now is the
pc versus console
which is the apple v frames
the fob is like not like oh my god
you're gonna be way better but there is
there are like let's say out of an
entire match if i
if i had somebody spectating me at 80
fov and i'm at 120 for example i don't
play at 120 but let's say if i was at
the max
there's probably one gun fight out of
every 30 engagements
where the fov would have allowed me to
see someone
that i wouldn't have seen on adfov so do
you think that
so you don't think that there's a
movement advantage with somebody
okay but how about this do you think
that the the uh
the ceiling is higher on mouse and
keyboard than uh
100 yes but don't you think then then
therefore
that would be an advantage no what ends
up happening
is uh console well controller in general
if we're [ __ ] just on controller
versus keyboard and mouse
i think the controller aspect is that
they do have aim assist and aim assist
actually is pretty decently strong it's
not broken in the game
but for the most part it's pretty strong
with the exception of stuns it's
overpowered it should
it shouldn't exist when you get stunned
um but the
average controller player that let's say
is quote unquote bad
um they're better than the bad keyboard
and mouse player
oh interesting you know i would i would
not have i would not have the average
player on controller is better than the
average keyboard and mouse player
because
it's just average because the aim assist
is helping quite a bit
and it's much easier to move on a
controller just because
when you have the the mobility of like
just an analog stick
versus when i input the key meta
keyboard like if i put down
something on the keyboard it does a 100
in it's not like i have
functionality you know what i mean um oh
you mean you mean to like
that little nuance a little yeah okay
yeah it's just a little bit different
um well then when you go to that next
level
the higher skill then that's where the
keyboard and mouse people separate
themselves
yeah that's what i'm saying the ceiling
is way higher i think like any and i
think certain guns are better on
keyboard and mouse than they are not
like
like
correct like the amax is one of those
guns that i think
on with uh with a controller and mouse
it's
it's it's different than i'm saying with
a keyboard and mouse versus controller
the amx has a way better gun on
on a keyboard and mouse is that do you
think that's true um i don't know i i
think it's hard to compare on that one i
think the amax is generally an easier
gun to use
i think one of those one the guns that
is uh one of those is the ram
for whatever reason the ram is just way
easier on keyboard and mouse than it is
on controller
not sure why it's just kind of how it
works but there are a few guns that are
like that where
it ends up being that way burst guns are
very similar to that too when we had the
m16
um that was and then the aug they were
better on controller just because
kind of like how the aim assist works i
don't know but yeah cause you because
you're
between every burst you're you're making
an adjustment
yep yeah so i do i do like that okay um
let's go to the next thing then it's
like um this is a big one right now is
that
so um i feel like to me i feel like the
integrity of the game is getting um
you know it's you know it's getting
messed up especially for like esports
and things like that yeah
tournaments because of this rampant
cheating problem
um i'm running in you know i don't know
if you saw that video that i made where
i was like doing an impersonation of you
and it was just like that one i could i
couldn't even believe
how i'm like and i feel like i'm running
into a cheater out of 10 games i'm
running into them like
not five to six times i'm running into
somebody where i go oh this seems
suspect
you know yeah yeah and it kind of sucks
because there's even scenarios where i
run into
and the kill cams are janky so that
makes it even more deceiving
yes because i i was like that guy had to
have been cheating
i go look up their stats they're like uh
like a 1.1 kd
and their headshot looks normal they
don't have an absurd win percentage
that was like their second kill in the
night right right right
well i always wait i always wait and see
though this is how i know when they're
cheating
it's like 28 kills 17 people watching
you know what i mean yeah yeah yeah
something's going on here yeah so it's
one of those things where
i think that's part of it um like they
have so many stupid hacks now i saw one
with iceman isaac
yesterday or the day before where the
guy was running a riot shield
and he had it on his back he started
getting shot he turned around
started running in the opposite
direction firing his weapon
and it was killing the guy behind him
yes it was like
that's what happened to me how the hell
does that work how the hell does that
work
i mean i feel like though that you know
before the pandemic
you know i felt like esports was
becoming a really big thing
you know people were going fill in
stadiums watching people play video
games
and so now when it went to home and it's
still sort of like that right now
and you know all these tournament
websites come up where you can win
money and this kind of things i think
that it's not a viable option right now
because the cheating is just so ridic
in those cronus devices and things like
that so it's like but
why do you think activision and the
makers of call of duty
why do you can they do something about
cheating
or do you think they even want to no i
think they have like a soft anti-cheat
which like
it'll detect people when they're blatant
but the problem with activision right
now is like i think they have like the
lazy route which is
it's based off reporting so for example
if a
certain person gets a certain number of
reports within a certain number of
matches or whatever
then it automatically red flags them to
be um
what's going to call it shadow band
which they don't even have a term on
activision for that like if you mention
shadow banning they like oh we don't
have that we don't even know what that
is what are you talking about but
essentially it gets thrown into these
lobbies which basically when you queue
up
it'll say uh 250 ping plus
you know when it says a thing and
normally it's 28 37
it goes up it'll start at 250 and it
just sits there
and then eventually it throws you in a
lobby
and your actual ping in game could be
like 60 because it just threw you in
with other shadow band people in your
area
but that's just like a placeholder to
throw you into a
blacklisted server i guess you can call
it because it's not whitelisted
and basically what will happen is at
that point
um that that impacts a manual review on
activision side
to go in and look at this person's
gameplay and discern whether or not the
person is cheating
so if the person gets shadow banned a
lot of times what they'll do
is they just swap over their next
account so is there no
actual programming way
there's no thing that they could build
into the game
to recognize cronus devices or these
hacks
is there no way to do that for regular
hacks i believe there is
um but like watching valerian for
example they
they built uh their engine
with the like forethought that hey we're
gonna have it to deal with hackers
and they already built in the engine
with hackers in mind
so their theirs is pretty strong but
they also have um
i can't remember the name for it where
basically
the it's invasive where you have to
install it it reads the files on your
computer
uh wow which people do not like they
they feel like it's a privacy issue
so there's push back on ballarat from
that type of stuff
but um there's that aspect
when it comes to cronus there's really
nothing that the game could legitimately
do
to counter the cronus back in the day
they used to
have a bigger issue with cronus i think
the only issue with cronus now
majority of the time is just anti-recoil
which for the most part
is not really an issue um because most
of the guns don't have a ton of recoil
but besides that part before it used to
be a uh what thing was called the jitter
mod
and they used to not like safeguard
their games before so for example
like the breckie and b03 used to have an
unlimited rate of fire
so if you were like a machine and you
could just spam the hell out of your
trigger
or you can spam the hell out of your
trigger you would
have infinite fire rate no matter what
whatever your trigger could go to
that's what it would be so there was no
limit um
then they put in safeguards where now
they have trigger caps
so if let's say it was 10 rpm which is
absurdly low
if i press this faster than 10 times a
minute
it would still only fire at that one
bullet every six seconds
got you there's a cap so the jitter mod
is no longer effective within current
cods
at least to my knowledge um
to solve for that issue and it also
happened with the 1911s i believe in
world war
ii but then they put in these trigger
caps which essentially
hard cap what the gun can fire at um so
those things counteract it so the only
thing that people mainly
people will say aim assist one the
videos i've seen of that just like look
like bad players
using like aim assist and not knowing
how to play
and make it look more snappy but in
reality like
it's not it's not like so then i mean
what do you think is going to happen
because you know i
i'm starting to get a feeling like you
know it's like you have this like
overall feeling where you know you run
into some cheaters and you're like all
right there's
oh that guy's a cheater but recently i
just feel like it's so
bad i just feel like it's like oh man
and then the problem i have with it is
you might run into a really great player
but because you've run into so many
cheaters
you're always suspect of a person now
yep and i think that that's activision
and
the makers of the game's fault now it's
like we're at this point where we're
just like oh man
you know uh was that that was that guy
cheating and then you have to like look
at the cam
you have to spectate for a little while
and you go you wait for like a couple of
shots and you go oh he's not cheating he
just got me that time
yeah like the fact that we are always
thinking that is a problem and it is a
problem and it's surprising that the
game has been able to be successful as
it is
and in my head it's like damn how
successful could the game be
because there's a lot of people that are
completely turned off by that like even
despite the hackers
you still play the game i still play the
game a bunch of people i know
still play the game and it's still an
issue and it's only gotten worse from
the launch of the game until now
there's obviously been little rolls
where it's been a little bit better um
where the hacking
kind of like dies out for a bit and then
it comes back it goes out comes back
and this has probably been the longest
stretch where it's like being consistent
hackers
cheaters on a regular basis and the game
is still thriving
and the activision's hitting the record
numbers quarter over quarter
they bring a new blueprint it's all sold
out basically as soon as it's in the
store
um so i don't know like i don't think
they have a lot of incentive to
change anything because it's working um
and if they are
i don't know why they wouldn't like
announce it say hey you know what
we're working on this problem that you
guys care about
right but like that would be like an hw
but from what you're saying
they don't even think it's a problem
because they're like what's the problem
everybody keeps playing and buying our
blueprints and this kind of stuff right
but then okay then address real quick
then about what i'm saying about
you know with it but then because like i
saw your video
where and i felt i felt your disdain
for this whoever this person was that
cheated in a
tournament you know what i mean like
this is like you know you got the call
of duty world series you got like
these are supposed to be these great
streamers who people admire and follow
and you know to know that they're
cheating or one of them's cheating
is like i think that that is a huge hit
to the integrity of
esports and streaming uh you know across
the board
yeah yeah that happened a while ago swag
had attorney with big boom
and there was a one guy that was
basically
like they didn't have enough eyeballs to
watch all the participants
and they kind of asked me hey could you
look at some of the clips just so that
you know maybe we get an extra set of
eyeballs and i was like yeah this guy i
think he's cheating
and then we do we got a few more people
involved and we were looking at clips
and it was clear that the guy was
cheating
then there was another guy which ended
up getting banned
three or four months later that i also
was suspicious of
but it was very hard to identify that
the guy was cheating
he ended up having the cheats that i
thought he had which is walls
and walls are one of the most difficult
things to spot
because most good players would be so
good at hiding them
right that like you would have to be
watching hours of footage
and literally looking hey how does this
guy know where every player is he gets
an engagement with
seems natural seems natural seems
natural all right let me add that one to
the sus one
and you're kind of compiling a case and
it's unfortunate that you would have to
do that
um and with enough eyeballs that's the
difference though
is that usually most of these top
streamers have so many eyeballs on them
that that for them to get away with
wall hack after wall hack after wall
hack would be would be damn near
impossible it would just be right
too obvious you're like you're like uh
it's like jay god csi you're like you
you look at everything and you know it's
unfortunate because
you have to even though i don't doubt
any of the big streamers like are
legitimate
like in my head when i watched a lot of
them for the first time
especially when i do the breakdowns of
top players
um i usually watch and sit in their
streams and a lot of times i don't even
follow the stream immediately
and i'll watch them for hours before
ever typing in the chat
so that like i could vet them in my own
mind and feel comfortable about
their gameplay yeah and only one person
i've ever talked about
ever got banned or or shadow banned or
anything
and that was magnificent and i looked at
his old gameplay
and i look at his new gameplay and i
don't know what the hell he had
because his stats are better and
i never thought he had anything but he
still got banned so it was like
how's that possible i don't think he's a
cheater like
i nothing about his gameplay screams
cheater but that was the only one that
was like ever felt like did i get it
wrong i don't know
and even to this day i believe he's not
a cheater
um i know people that have played with
him for long periods of time even when
he
will demon it's like
like how that happened like how did
someone accidentally get banned i mean
unless it was something innocent
and we don't know and it never got
talked about or was complete accident
right man that's uh
oh man it's like you know you you
i mean i guess it's just it's just like
you have
to weigh it it's like there's the
popularity of this game
and the and the the actually how we talk
about it too i mean it's just like
it almost like any any press is good
press type of thing
you know so i guess if the game was
perfect and there was no cheaters and
all this
would we even find it interesting so
maybe like
you know what i mean it's all part of
the the thing that makes it what it is
yep so one of the questions i got a lot
from people
is like so like they wanted like what's
your go-to loadout like when you're just
playing
like like like do you have like a gun
that you love
that it's just like i always want this
gun or even if it's like it's like one
of your favorites
no no i don't really have that i kind of
just stick to whatever the the meta is
and
luckily the meta has been expanded so i
have about five or six loadouts i just
play between
um a lot of times now when i'm playing
the game
um actually playing it i'm usually
thinking about trying to get content for
my second channel
which i'll upload just hey you know i
got 15 kill game on rebirth using the
loadout like the typical youtuber for
cod
um so a lot of times i'll use weapons
that are mostly
once i go through all the meta weapons
then i'll start using a couple off meta
but still like top viable
it's not like i'm going to pull out a
trash can i'm going to be like yeah
let's let's rock the magnum today it's
not going to happen
um but like i would love it i would love
that
i would love to see you rock a m60
magnum loadout that's the challenge
you ever do that you ever have like a uh
like a challenge like that oh you go
like no no no
you're not like
that phenomenal where i can literally
pick up rock paper scissors and i'm
gonna be
like destroying the lobby you know i got
this potato here i'm going to just
mail everyone no it ain't like that
here's a pomegranate and a snapshot and
we're going to see what we can do like
you don't do that oh man
me personally i don't i hate using the
metaguns i really do
like i i still have a odin loadout i'll
still like you know what i mean i still
i like to win
i just i like the challenge of winning
with a loadout that like no one else is
using i just that's just
i just like doing that because i mean
i'm like i say i'm not
great at the game you know i'm an old
man playing the game so when i win i i
i get exil i love that feeling you know
what i mean i just i just love it
so you wouldn't consider yourself like
um like
so you wouldn't consider yourself like
those top streamers you know when they
get you no they're not even 30
30. that's not you even close no no no
no um like i think if if i could go back
and do it all over again and start like
focusing on gaming seriously when i was
in my 20s
early 20s got you hell yeah let's do it
but now that i'm 33
there's nobody doing wagers that's like
the oldest is 30.
and these guys were pro players so like
their loss to step is still like 10
steps better than my step at 33 you know
type thing
yeah so i i think like
also to get to those levels you have to
put in like you have to be very
passionate
not only about like what i'm doing on
the back end stuff but
you have to be very passionate about
playing the game eight to ten hours a
day
right like it's a big problem exactly
but you're
in the gym but you're a professional now
right because this is like
you've made this your job i mean right
is it yeah yeah you've made this your
job and
congratulations on that you know it's
like you know this
you're like the champion of stat geeks
you know yeah yeah yeah
you know i mean it's like it's like
nerds unite and you're in the forefront
like you know keep doing you
it's it's you know it's an inspiration
to people out there who are like look i
i'm not an athlete or i'm not i'm not
great at this and you're like
i you're great at what you do so it's
like and you've made a living at it so i
think that's pretty fantastic man
yeah thank you thank you yeah i think it
it
initially i always thought like hey you
know what i focus on being that good at
the game because i was
playing like an absurd amount of hours
but then
as i kind of took a step back like i
wasn't putting in those hours so i can't
expect to get those same results
but in my head mentally i don't see
myself playing the game eight to ten
hours a day
i don't know how top streamers do it
daily i mean i guess because when you're
a demon like it just feels like
slight work you know i'm like sweating
every match every gun fighting
but i think yeah war zone is the kind of
thing where it's like
the game's 30 minutes long so yep
like like you know so if you think about
it like that if you're a really great
player
you're going 25 minutes deep every
single game
yeah so four games is already
two hours almost right yeah yeah
so to get to like six hours it ain't
even that big a deal
you know that is true that is like 12
matches yeah you like 12 matches and
you're just like what
what what's going on here all right
listen man i'm going to go we're about
to wind it down because i know i don't
want to keep you too much longer but let
me go live on twitch right now and we're
going to go
and you're going to criticize my
loadouts
[Music]
and then uh that'll be uh you know and i
think i think that people will be like
really shocked even like you know
because everybody was like it's like we
we
people have been tweeting at you for
like a year now i don't know if you've
even seen them like a lot of people from
my stream are always like
okay guys you got to go on roofing with
griffin and so i feel like i've seen in
the past
three to six three three six months or
so yes man something like
we're on my channel talking about it i'm
like why is jake got big time in me man
you know what's funny i don't even know
what you're doing
right for some reason in my head i
thought i had already followed you
because yeah and then you didn't follow
me back that was another thing i was
like this bastard
and then i and i saw it i was like oh
shoot i'm not even following him
let me go ahead and follow because
normally you know and then i
i follow whoever like i'm not really
thinking about it like that
well you know what i shouldn't be i've
been bad-mouthing you this whole time so
i'm so glad of you
i'm glad i'm glad i got the truth about
this finally you know what i mean but
that's like
so um all right let me do this now uh
you know i'm on here on twitch and we'll
see i mean
they'll populate whenever they want i
mean my i call my guys pieces of [ __ ]
you know so the pos army
that's my guys
they're just monsters like by the way
like how do you even deal with cause i'm
sure you get a lot of trolls or
or do you just ignore the noise like how
do you even deal with that
well i i think it like at a certain
point like one of the things i really
prided myself on
as i was becoming a like a larger
content creator
was i would read every single comment i
would heart it or i'd engage with it if
i could
i would read through them so if it made
sense to reply i would reply
um so i was able to see like like 99
percent positive and then you get
you know you're toxic in there and most
people they'd go oh my god i can't
believe you replied like most big
youtubers don't reply i'm like i have
like 30 000 subscribers i'm not i'm not
like a huge youtuber you know
i don't even have a silver play button
yet you know type thing um and then time
went on
it became like almost too much and what
you notice quick about the algorithm is
the betters your videos do
that means your youtube is recommending
you more to people that don't know who
you are
and as a result of that you get more
talk
that's the trolls and then it's like
well is this person even real
like or do they really believe this
standpoint
of like absurdity you know and
it's kind of one of those things that
you know you don't really know so you
kind of got to disengage because
i would wake up and i'd spend three
hours reading comments
like on a youtube video were you
obsessing well
you have an obsessive personality that's
the only way you can do all these stats
and i was like there's no way
i can spend my time doing this i just
don't have time in the day for that
and then twitter started popping off and
then it's like well now i have too many
mentions and too many random dms from
people now i got to close off my dms
because
it would be too many people hey jay god
i got a question and then i'd be like
all right is this a real question or not
like right right why didn't you ask your
damn question
so i can see what the question is so i
know if i need to respond and then
sometimes i'd respond early on and
they'd be like
oh can we play some time right then it
always turns into that you know
like i get that a lot on my channel too
i get it i get on my channel people go
hey man can we play
and i'm like i don't know you
i got so many friends legitimately like
there's even players
like where i know them in the community
and they're like hey
play sometimes and i'm like yeah i mean
i just play on random
so like literally you have to be online
and you have to have a spot open so i
could join because
literally i'll go to some this is how
sometimes i'll go i'll go to bobby pop
stream that's one of the
guys that i normally try to jump in with
because he plays a lot of rebirth
i go in i look at his uh stream there's
three icons from discord up there's a
spot
like hey bobby you got a spot he's like
hell yeah i jump in jay god i jump into
the chord i play for an hour two i play
for three hours i play for no
like one match it doesn't matter and
that's just kind of how it is other
people be like hey could we play
sometime i was like
well i'm not really playing right now
i'm testing because we just had a brand
new update
yeah you're not you're like the thing
you love me for i have to spend a lot of
time doing
i can't spend the time playing with you
you know
you nincompoops you know what i mean
so it's kind of crazy how that part goes
and then obviously on twitter
uh twitch now when i scream it's always
like because of that whole like
hacker illuminati that people think all
those big teamers
streamers cheating they'd be like hey
did you see that uh you know aiden
he's cheating is like what right you're
talking about aiden in my stream
yeah i didn't bring up aiden yeah him
i think he's a very talented player i
think he's one of the best in the game
hands down not cheating but like
you're coming in my chat trying to
change the subject we're talking about
something else like what what is your
problem bro like
and that's their only comment it's like
really like yeah i know
they say hi what's wrong with you yeah
yeah man they just come in and they just
like immediately attack i mean it's such
a
it's such a bizarre thing and then for
me too like when i'm
you know it's like you're playing and
you're kind of like glancing over at
your comments you know
and it's it would be like if you're in a
room at a party
and there's no music playing and you can
hear people talking and i'm in the other
side of the room and i just go
yeah man that jay guy dude he's a he's a
piece of [ __ ] you know
yeah and like you i can hear you
you know what i mean and and that's what
these people do in the comments they say
like the most outlandish things
that's what i mean i'm sure you have
mods and stuff right do you like
how many times have you do you
personally give out timeouts i mean how
are you on that
i do sometimes what'll end up happening
is sometimes
be like i'll see a comment and sometimes
the mod bandit or whatever
um or i'll just call the dude out and
just be like
you know what the hell is your problem
let's like look at your chat this is
your first message in my chat and you
decide
and i and sometimes like when it gets
toxic or there's a good amount of
viewers because i was having my
tournament thing
yeah i put in like 30 minute followers
so people couldn't even comment unless
they
but then they would wait 30 minutes and
leave a stupid comment i'm like this man
wait 30 minutes to say something stupid
the other day the other day i gave
somebody a hundred thousand
i gave him a hundred thousand second
timeout like [ __ ]
get off my channel you know so you you
been for you man for a month
yeah yeah exactly you can come back when
you're ready yeah
so i i think it just gets a little bit
weird when people are just absurdly
weird instead of just being positive
it's like what do you got going on i'm
sure obviously you sure
you know you've dealt with a lot of
hecklers and irl
like you know when you do your thing
yeah and i'm sure you just get used to
it at a certain point where it's like
all right i've seen a thousand of you
you've only done this once i already
know how to respond to this school you
know
you know the problem with that too is
like that's the thing is i'm not your
normal streamer
you know i'm a stand-up comedian i'm an
actor like i
like you say i deal with real people in
real life saying stuff to me
and i go at them a lot of these nerds
here
they just don't know how to deal with
that like when i come back at them
they really get like oh my god i thought
you were a comedian
i thought it was okay to do it's like no
no no this is what i do
you're gonna get told and that's this is
how it is you know what i mean
they're just not used to like people
having such a boisterous personality on
it because a lot of these streamers are
just
dull you know i think that's what you
were commenting on earlier you know
all right guys listen i'm live on twitch
right now and this is the great jay guy
we finally got him on guys and
you know so if you want to watch the
whole episode you got to watch riffing
with griffin so i came on live right now
because before i let him go
i want him to look at my loadouts and
and uh you know tell me
what he thinks of so of course
my first one here is i got my fully
loaded loadout like we were talking
about so i got my gra
you know what i mean it's like you know
so i got the monolithic the tempus
uh commando 50 round mag and i go fully
loaded
so i get that one when i drop it and
then i'm just ranking up this scott this
uh whatever i cough is good why don't
you
fully level so i'm ranking it up right
now so i could still so i could still
say
ghost i could be ghosts and i could
still have a really great secondary gun
right
yep so this is the only thing i would
change probably with that
is the perks like you have tracker on
which is cool
but what happens is if you're getting
this as a ghost loadout if you're
getting overkill
then amped is a better option than
tracker but if you're staying with the
psycov
then tracker is okay because you don't
need a fast weapon swap because the
pistol swaps
fast okay good all right all right nice
cause you're playing solos mostly or
you're playing i play a lot of i
actually do both i play
a lot of solos but then i'll play with a
couple of my buddies we play the duos
and trios a lot too but
for the most part i play a lot of solos
so yeah if you play trios then i would
probably convert the 50 to a 60 meg
but that's obviously in that mode so you
would just do a case by case
the difference in ads speed is so
negligible between those you really
probably won't even feel the difference
it's like it's like a one frame i'm glad
you were saying that let me ask you
something
do we just ignore these like things at
the bottom there the with the green and
the red
are those accurate at all they they are
accurate to
uh based off the behind the scenes stats
but the problem is an example like if
you go to your your perks
go to uh slide ahead uh-huh
uh or the weapon perk sorry oh it's
overloaded go to sleight of hand
and you're gonna see that that it
increases the fire rate which we know is
not true
oh oh got you got you got you guys so
when you go to the
that and yeah slight of hand it says
this is your fire rate it doesn't
it doesn't make sense to do that but in
reality what happens is let's say you
you're firing consecutively for one
minute
um the fact that you reload faster means
you'll get more bullets out within one
minute
so technically that stat bar moved
because it is accurate but it's not
really
accurate in terms realistic so
why don't people every now that we're in
this screen right now why don't people
ever use like
these other things like frangible is
that is that a viable
this crippling power is that viable in
groups i always feel like in a group
play this might be a good
you're like the guy that's shooting
people's legs and then everybody else
can kill him or
is that a viable perk in war zone not
really because
it only applies when people don't have
plates on
oh i didn't even know that so they have
to hit their
regular health bar but this is something
i struggle with i actually tested
and it didn't feel like it worked within
warzone but i later came to find out
that it worked
but the person you had to break their
armor
so in reality they'd be like almost one
shot yeah they're one shot anyway okay
well they're like they're not gonna
really see the effect
i'm glad you said that all right let's
go to my next one real quick okay so the
the top three are that's my fully loaded
i drop in i need that guns
and then i have a smg ghost one which
i'm using the milano so sometimes i'm
just dropping it i'm going to grab
this so i did that i did this one with
the three-time scope on it because then
it
it's actually great at range and it's
great you know
you know yeah for close quarters so
weird yeah actually you probably want
the bigger mag
instead of uh what do you what do you
have instead of like maybe the
like but what but i don't know what
would i take off oh i see what you're
saying
but i like having that extra damage do
you think that that extra damage is real
on that well that's that's that's
damage range i think is 10 so for
example if this
damage drop off is like 22 meters then
it would it would increase it by 2.2
meters so you'd be up to 24 meters
well that's and i think i think that's
why i keep it with the three-time scope
on it right
well no because what ends up happening
is that two meter difference
would the the the odds the times that
you get into a gunfight where somebody
was with between 22
and 24 meters within that two meter span
where like it's actually going to
benefit you is negligible
oh this is oh my god you're this whether
you're jay guy this is what okay
so now i'm changing so so you're saying
take the target designator off put on
the clip
okay so what should i 55 fast round or
regular 55
regular 55 okay regular 55 drum and take
off the target designator so
and is that do you think that's true on
all the guns with the target designator
do you think it's even worth using at
all
tarzan detonator i have to retest it on
shotguns
but the the only uh loadouts where it
made sense to use them on
was shotguns because there's really only
two attachments that increase your range
and shotguns i believe
which is the the suppressor and then the
laser which was the target designator
and it ended up doing like more
percentage on shotguns for whatever
reason
so like for example with the gallow when
you were using that it would allow you
to get up to like
nine and a half meters instead of like
seven six
got you that two meters is completely
different because
there's so many engagements where seven
to nine meters
is literally the difference between one
extra shot or not
where you're gonna lose a gunfight
versus with this 22 meters is kind of a
rare
like a rarer you're usually closer or
like 40 meters plus
got you and then i just have this gun
here just for no reason other than to
have fully loaded on it
just to so my other gun is fully loaded
when i drop in
once you get your slack level obviously
you'd probably swap that out
yes the uh the the dmodi no no not the
diamond um
the the rene you can do the same thing
um
and those ones are a little bit more
practical but obviously if you're
swapping it out for
just to get fully loaded yeah and you
look like a sorry pistol
because by the way by the way i feel
like on this new update
the ground guns are too good i picked up
a gold craig
earlier and i got second place in a solo
and i was like i
what i did was i draw i i just picked up
this and picked up that gold crate yeah
and it was so good i was like this is
too good
to be on there i got buffed yeah yeah
well the the rest of the floor loot
isn't all that great like the amp
is garbage like i think it's a terrible
pistol oh that
that shooting one okay yeah it's a fully
auto amp 63 i think it's called
yeah it sucks all right so then my next
one is like another ghost so sometimes
like maybe i maybe i pick up somebody's
mp5 i killed
and then the loadout comes and then i'll
just get my ghost which is the [ __ ]
solos it's way more forgiving on your
loadout you can pretty much pick up
anything as long as you get like a
milano off the floor or
right mac 10 you're okay you know you
got long range
feel comfortable with now this is how i
have mine set up but like you know you
know you could correct me please you
know i
i got my no that looks right that looks
like the normal build that most people
will use the only thing is you might
want to do grew suppressor which would
be a little bit slower
but you get a little bit more bullet
velocity but that one comes down to
preference
one thing you could do is do the grew
suppressor for example and then if you
wanted to put on the uh rp you know was
the
the ranger barrel was what's the barrel
the other one i can't remember the name
right now
uh liberator the liberator has the same
bullet velocity as the rpk
a little bit less recoil control but it
aimed down sight
it makes up for the groove okay so when
i when i i always get
fooled by these red lines so when i like
i say when i'm looking at this thing and
i literally i go look at the damage drop
off is that i mean so is that accurate i
mean it's like
that damage is more the range so for
example with that gun if it has like a
35 meters
and then it has like a 10 meters or 20
meter difference or 20
difference well you're talking about six
meters different so you end up with that
same scenario we talked about where
you're going up from 36 meters to 39
but if you're using this like in like
the normal way you would use it you're
probably going to use it for 50 meters
plus 40 meters plus
and then it really that doesn't really
come down to impact the gunfight
okay liberator done and then like the
grips you know i have this like you know
you know i like that yeah that's is the
way to go you know and then i have the
60 round mag
you know what i mean okay boom all right
so there's that loadout and then i have
a
what i call a my retired garbage loadout
but right now i have something good in
it but like i had retired the c58 for a
second and then i brought it back
yeah yeah it's it's so good i don't know
what i mean
so this is what i have to double check
to double check and see if it's still
broken
but the 4x it had a better recoil
properties than the 3x
okay but my problem with the forex is
now that
goes into my ads numbers
it affects so it was slower because i
have that slower
yeah yeah so then so then my gun was
slower
yeah so but you still think it's worth
trying with the 4x or should i just keep
the 3x
i would try the 4x just to see how it
feels i tried it last night when i was
leveling uh
my smg the new smg um and
i was like yeah they didn't doesn't feel
like they nerfed this at all the only
thing you'll want to do with this is
you'll probably want to change the optic
or uh the reticle yeah yeah um so you
customize that and then you can change
that reticle
yeah i have my reticle but what about
all this other stuff i have on it so
no that stuff looks fine range ranger
task force same argument that we kind of
went back and forth with the uh got you
and then like depends and i have this
one because i like the recoil control
the field agent and then like oh i got
the i
had the fast mag on this but you think i
should go with just a regular 55
with regular 55. this thing actually
reloads really fast
um i think it's like one and a half
seconds compared to like the pharah's
almost like three
like two and a half seconds so it
reloads fast on its own
you might as well not penalize yourself
on the aim down sight and then what i
did also was like i love i went back to
the bullfrog you know i i
not the bullfrog the the bison so this
is my bison setup and i love the bison
it feels good i
i don't know i mean you still you you
haven't touched the bison in so long i
think after this update there's gonna be
a lot more smgs into the mix
um i actually preferred the bullfrog
because it had the same um
whatchamacallit same damage profile i
don't know about now i have to double
check but
it had the same damage profile but the
bullfrog fired 100 rpm faster
which basically mean in every scenario
the bullfrog killed faster than the
bison
because it literally just shoots faster
but does the same damage
they've done enough damage changes to
both of the weapons that maybe it's
different now
but uh okay but let me ask you this
though that's i'm so glad you said that
but then it becomes a style situation
though because
for me if a gun shoots too fast
i find myself losing that fight because
i've
i've wasted all my bullets before i've
made the adjustment yeah
it depends on right individual i think
uh
the benefit with this type of build for
example though is you have better hip
accuracy um which is is nice you
probably have decent strafe speed
so like you're a hip fire player which i
think
most uh like players
are like are split on that some people
never hit fire and then some people do
hit fire
i'm finding that i have to hip fire now
more
than before because once i start aiming
down sight these guys are jumping out of
the way and i'm like
you know what i mean so i'm finding that
i have to hip fire and then
aim assist kicks in a little faster too
when you do that too right
yep yep so i think with this it ends up
being like a decent build for hip fire
maybe get some bullets in there
um and any reason why you use a prox
mine over like a claymore
i find that they're both garbage in
different scenarios
because i find that to claymore people
first of all it's it's noticeable
so where you put it is like you know
like you can see it through doors
like somebody's coming up the stairs
they see those red
those red lasers more than anything else
and people are jumping right over them
i use the proximity mine because it
still hits them you know you maybe
you'll get even if it's just one play
but i find that the players are moving
so fast right now
that neither one of them are as good as
they were yeah
they were before and i'm like they you
could go they just ran right past my
mind but if you throw two of them down
like like sometimes i like in a building
like there's just one building downtown
i go to all the
the kids call it griff tower you know
what i mean so i uh
so like i'll be like i'll put one by the
elevator and then i'll put one where i
know they run
when once they get hit yeah and then
that'll get them you know
because you got to double up yeah yeah i
got it doubled up so you know that's the
only reason why
i do that uh let me just quickly go
through these other so i have like
i just started sniping so this is one of
my so i have this
for my my sniper support is my uh yeah
got nerfed hard for sniper support oh
man so what do you think now
i don't know yet i think uh it kind of
is hard because they kind of destroyed a
lot of the uh rifles
for the close range ttk so before this
thing used to kill sub 600 now it's 666
i believe
um for its short range which means that
you're gonna get beat by every smg like
right before it was at least close
now it's like well do you think it grows
not getting anything
you better not get pushed or push the
building you know type thing
okay so so xm4 out at sniper support
i don't know necessarily out yet get the
the the verdict's not 100 there
okay but i think it's killing a little
bit too slow where
you're not you're gonna be at a
disadvantage like
like if you're not if you're running a
sniper you're kind of at a disadvantage
because your gun just there's no jack of
all trucks like we had we've been kind
of spoiled
by having the xm4 the pharah the ak-47
the
rifle right all these guns that can
provide both
now most of them aren't killing fast
enough up close to solve for that
problem so
i think uh we'll have to kind of wait
and see on that one all right okay i
mean
just a couple oh this is one of these um
things that uh
uh well okay so i have like i i like the
og i like the although
the the modern warfare og i love this
gun i think it's great up close
that's cool as an smg 30 round mag 556
kills pretty fast
yeah i think this is solid build if you
put on the 60 it'd be way too damn slow
but right
right but but when i'm playing group
play i might do that
with the you know just to have the
bullets yeah but like i know what you're
saying about that
all right so there's that and then
here's my lmg
uh i watched one of your videos and i
love using calvary lancer because i love
wrecking berthas with oh those things
destroy
yeah i love it the stoner did get a
slight nerf i think
um so i it's still good though i think i
think
either way it's still good so according
to you then i should take this target
designator off and put
ammo on this one huh you could put ammo
if you if you don't mind the reload the
way it is now
uh you could do ammo like fast mag or
120
but if you wanted to like have a better
aim down sight you could go with the
rear grip and put on like the elastic
elastic wrap all right this will give it
better okay i'm gonna do that like way
better it takes off like 60 milliseconds
or something oh wow man
okay now i feel like the ak-74u
it was becoming good
and now they now they ruined it again
right i feel like it was out and now is
it still out like what do you think
um i have to plug in the data from what
the what they what they said they
updated so i'm not 100 sure
i would feel like they they buffed it
for range but then they nerfed it up
close so
i think people weren't using it before
so i don't think a lot of people will be
using it now
especially since it's one of the slower
aim down sights in the game
like for the smg category okay all right
so that one's
the big get go all right i'm going to
come back to that and this is my
experimental
loadout because i have it so i'm using
the for sniper support i'm using the m13
you know m13 let me double check that
because i already updated that stat
uh let me double check pretty sure
the m13 twitch what do you guys think
let me go
don't think it kills fast enough up
close it's the same thing with the xm4
but at range it does kill faster now um
but you are using it like for super fast
aim down side
better hip higher build yes you put let
me see
what do you think no i think that's good
i think that's about as all you can do
the tempus cyclone
gives you suppression uh bullet velocity
um with with no tracers i don't know if
you know that part with the integrated
barrels they don't have uh
tracers oh really actually it's still i
still see the
i still see the yellow tracer well
that's probably because you have a
the tracer pack yeah i do you don't have
tracer pack
you won't see tracers oh okay all right
because i just got the blueprint of it
you know yeah yeah
but i felt like i felt like it was
messing up the gun
is that a real thing with the tracers
yeah
like i think they just distract you
they're kind of annoying my opinion i
have never
you know what i agree but i just like i
liked it
yeah that's just a person it's a
preference thing i don't know why i like
it yeah it's flashy it's fun
and you are you a sniper guy i mean
because like i i've been trying this
pelington and i've i really like i like
wellington's cool i think the the swiss
and the car are the best two snipers
though
swiss in the car okay uh one almost done
so i have my uh xm xm you know
loadout and this is how i have it set up
yeah yeah that's a pretty standard
build takedown um i mean you don't
necessarily need that range i'd either
go with the ranger or the
the task force okay uh let's go ranger
thank you sir
[Laughter]
and then um 45 is good for ads speed
especially if you're playing solos
yeah um you just can't get caught
reloading like if you're shooting oh
yeah
and then you get like somebody jumps out
on you that's the worst yeah it reloads
like a it reloads like a magnum you know
it's ridiculous
and then i had the lc10 but i saw that
on your thing i saw your video last
night you you felt like they
they nerfed this to the ground you think
huh um i i have to double check again
like i said i haven't updated all the
smg stuff i just went through and did
all the rifles
um lmg stuff so those are all accurate
on my spreadsheet as far as the ttks
okay um but i have to go back through
and do the math on the
the smgs okay so we'll get the better
verdict like
i never thought i'd say that qvz was
pretty decent good
but now the qbc is like actually worth
using which is kind of dumb now is that
is a qbz worth using a sniper support
no no no no like i said most of the
rifles still struggle at
close range ttk okay so you're gonna be
like penalized no matter what you use up
close
okay so so you so you're then suggesting
that for sniper support
smg oh well even then that's hard but
maybe the milano could be still good
sniper support
um because of the range that it has yeah
yep
unless you're oh i see what you're
saying so unless you're like really good
at sniping
you know those people that can quick
scope and all that which i always feel
like they're cheating when they do that
i just i don't understand how people do
that
it's i don't you know you know what you
know what's another thing that really
bugs me man is like
like i have a sniper and someone's
shooting at me and my [ __ ] is jumping
all over the place
so i always feel like if i'm shooting at
somebody and i'm getting hit markers and
they still snipe me
they're cheating that's just how i feel
about it that feels like that
i was like how the hell did that happen
how all right and my last loadout is i
have my tack load outside because i
still love the tactical rifle so
i still got my m16 and then solos i
think it's only good in solos
i think it's only good in solos but like
uh because in group play you really
you're not hitting your shots to where
you can you know what i mean so
and i have it set up like this yeah
unless they're running across an open
field
yeah yeah yeah you know but i do like
the idea of being able to like shoot and
make the adjustment because i'm that
kind of player where i can make a little
adjustment but
if i'm shooting a gun that shoots too
fast like the mac 10 i can't play with
it
because by the time i by the time i make
the adjustment
all the bullets are gone yeah that's
always been the downside with that gun
is just the damage per mag is way too
low
yeah it's just yeah man well you know
what i think um
and i do i still have the mag 10 in it i
i still try you know because up close
it's like you know it is what it is
and i haven't set up i would still use
the uh the task force for that one
okay task four let's see i think
like if the mag issue was issued before
they nerfed this one so it's gonna
be a bigger issue now i think all right
i feel you well man i really appreciate
you being on
um this has been great you know it's
like i've been i've
you don't know i've been looking forward
to this and i've been i've made it i
made it happen
i think my egot uh meet jay god video is
the thing that put us over the edge
but look you know from me and all of the
the cod you know i'm going to speak for
the whole cod
universe we completely and utterly
appreciate everything that you do
please continue doing what you do
because i we we can't play the game
without you we need we need those
spreadsheets we need those numbers so we
can like uh
be be viable out here and uh thank you
very much
thank you very very much for being here
and i and uh and i'll keep in touch man
so you know maybe when
it will have you have you on a game when
with something big to talk about but i
appreciate you for being on man
thanks for being here thank you thank
you
all right cool i just got i just got off
twitch um leo
yeah man thanks a lot and you know i'll
i'll let you know i'm just
i can just go to one of your youtube
videos and grab all your information you
know i see all like you know you have
all that stuff and i'll put that in my
thing and i'll
and when i put it out i usually put it
out on monday i'm probably gonna put
this one out on monday
and i'll send you the links and all you
know you'll you'll know the link if you
could just you know tweet that out for
me all that kind of stuff yeah great
sure
yeah i think people really love this and
uh and like i say if you ever you know
if you ever want me to jump in with you
and play it that'd be fun too
to do to do that too i think rebirth is
where i've been spending most of my time
because i
love playing play you know on saturdays
man i do uh custom matches with the fans
on saturdays yeah i do custom rebirth i
saw something about that that you
tweeted out
yeah that's what i like to do so so that
because then i it's fun
you know yeah but i one thing i do wish
that they did
with the rebirth with with the customs
is i wish you can actually customize it
oh yeah yeah you know i wish you funny
is when they first leaked the private
matches they actually had customizable
stuff
but then like when it actually came out
literally nothing's touchable
i don't understand it because to me like
on custom matches it should always be a
jailbreak
always you know what i mean like you
know what i mean i wouldn't want to fix
that
and i i would also want to make it where
i can remove guns like you can't play
with this gun
or you can only play with these five
guns just to make it fun that's the
problem with the competitive scene right
now is
they want to do customs but then they
can't limit the weapons so they can't
like everything would be
gentlemen's agreement but it's like oh
am i just supposed to walk past
a a floor loot you know whatever yeah
yeah yeah
yeah like am i just supposed to walk
past it because i got bad rng when i
landed
and this guy got a regular like a gun
that's not g8 and i'm not supposed to
pick it up
yeah how dare you pick up that rpg and
shoot my bertha
right right right man so but but anyways
i do do custom so if you ever want to
jump in on that with your
you know you know then we could get like
a real 100 because i cause i don't
always do the war zone one i i've been
doing the rebirth once
mini ones because you can get more
you're a hassle to set up right like
yes man oh by the way yes you know what
the biggest problem with it is
is like you have too many people on your
friends list you can't add people
they don't make it easy to add people to
the game
and so now i haven't been for a while
they had the regiments broken so you
couldn't even do it that way
is the regiment still broken did they
fix that i think they fixed it but
one one thing that does work um i don't
know if you you do you
have discord on the same uh you because
you game on a computer
i no i game on my xbox but i do have
discord i can use my discord no the
reason why i was asking is because if
you are on pc
and you happen to have discord on the
same pc you can actually
in just be in discord and you can open
invite and people automatically be able
to join through discord oh
that's a pc specific thing so if you
have your discord though
what you could do is you could have
maybe somebody who has a mod
like for you like the mods for you that
you you feel comfortable with that maybe
that you could say hey
could you host it and then you'll get in
there through a regular invite
and then they'll put the link in the
discord and then if there's like 30
people want to jump in or 50 or however
many people
oh really just click on that and if they
are playing on pc with discord
they'll automatically just click it and
join the lobby no invites or anything
needed
that's interesting okay i'll have to
think of that because that is a major
like i think that the customs would be a
lot better if they made it
easier to join yeah because it feels
like kind of like a chore
yes it would be like a community driven
thing that's just fun yes
man yes i'm you know i'm so glad i'm
still recording so i'm gonna put this in
this is great
yeah exactly it's just bad but yeah i
would like i even had that with mine
because my discord is actually set up on
my
like regular streaming pc right my game
is on a gaming pc so there's no other
apps or anything on that it's just right
oh gosh i can't do that
so what i did is i had one of my mods he
said hey i'll do it i had him join the
lobby and then he
hosted it and people would just fill up
boom boom boom boom boom boom
that's what you want because i would
like for once to have 150 fans in the
game
yup like doing like awards but i don't
like doing those warzone ones because
then i'm sitting here waiting
every single time i'm waiting 30 minutes
yeah you know so that's why i went to
the mini
the mini all right join up now join us
yeah join them yeah
then if i die right away i'm like oh
this is terrible yeah
you know and they should also make it
where the the leader
can jump in between i could they should
make it so i can go to whoever
yeah yeah yeah they should have like a
caster mode where you can spectate
different
differences yes man well you know maybe
we'll put that out there in the universe
but anyways you know what since i'm
still going
i want to say thanks again to jay god
for being on the podcast this has been
riffing with griffin and i will see you
guys next week
you